the man who called so many remarkable
matches at the u.s
open including a five-set tiebreak the
man who
who's uh who puts the the team if you
will
not only in the winner of the us open
but the the team player
uh who not only called all that action
over the weekend
for espn but is calling tonight's game
along with kirk herb street and maria
taylor as he always does for college
football but tonight's
nfl game between the giants and the
steelers my friend chris fowler here on
the show how are you chris
i'm starting out the window at metlife
stadium across the turnpike here
contemplating uh what comes next i'm
well
it's it's exciting kind of surreal yep
but it says very 2020. you know
empty but intense arthritis stadium
empty but intense metlife stadium the
next night why not
i was going to say to you you're you're
one of the few announcers who were
calling uh a week one nfl game who
already knows what it's like to call
an intense affair in front of hardly
anybody
i mean what was that like sitting in
arthur ash the last uh
couple of weeks certainly over the
weekend overused the word surreal
now bizarre to see someone like serena
on the court with zero fans
and and to see a ghostly empty
place for the men's final and but i i
tell you what what i've noticed
in the tennis is what i've seen in the
nba playoffs certainly the nhl playoffs
haven't had a huge sample of games in
the nfl i watched a couple but
the on field or on-court intensity is
not diminished one iota in fact it's
almost easier to put the focus on that i
think fans who watch football games
you're not going to get those crowd
shots they're not going to get the roar
but you're going to get i think
a more intense focus on the participants
and the sounds of it i'm not trying to
sell
fanless football i can't wait till
crowds get back in it but in trying to
adapt and adjust and see what's
different
like in tennis we were able to just
really focus in on
you could hear the players breathing on
the court it was just
very weird but what i noticed was
they competed just as hard they wanted
to win just as badly
they didn't get anything back from the
crowd but they didn't need it and in
that case i don't think nfl players are
going to need it either
no espn did not uh pipe in whistles
right for bad line calls during the us
open
that they did not do that right the same
we're hearing stuff for the nfl
i think humans humans are going to be
endangered species when it comes to
calling lions at a lot of major
tournaments they're going to go to pure
technology
right off the bat and and do away with
the challenge system and just
let the machines do it that's probably
the future well i mean it's safer if
yokovich is on the court too chris right
wow is that wrong is it too soon
i mean she's recovered thankfully the
lines and when he hit the adam's apple
no it's i think i i did a video
afterwards and i don't i don't know how
this football season or the rest of the
sports calendar is going to play out you
guys are talking about some twists and
turns in the playoffs
right i think buckle up we're going to
see unpredictable stuff that's
it's hard to expect and hard to
to explain to people because it's just
20 20 man and nothing is normal
um i i think that you're going to have
unlikely outcomes
and i think it's going to be a serious
mental
test in the nfl as the season goes on
guys
any sport guys who are opting in now you
can still be opting in when your teams
like three and six i mean
i hope i hope it's a positive statement
about the culture
of these teams so they can keep guys
together because we're all going through
stuff in our own way but
it's just it just as it's a
challenging tough year on the planet
it's going to be the same in the sports
landscape so
let me ask you guys no no chris that's
what i feel come on chris
it's not it's not dave i mean like look
we're all we're all trying to figure
stuff out
you know i i'm i'm waking up every day
checking the the air index to see if
it's healthy for my kids to go out
you know on their pe classes that they
have
in quotes during their you know online
learning i mean it's
a crazy world we're living in right now
chris fowler joining me here
uh getting set to call the monday
nighter between the giants and the
steelers and before we get to that
what do you know about your college
football schedule as you're currently
sitting here
right now what do you know about that
it's funky
i mean i think you know we the big ten
is gonna have their their big decision
about whether or not they're gonna try
to crank things up it's still possible
they could crank things up much sooner
than people expect
and try to squeeze the season in there
they could somehow
uh put them in in position to be in the
playoff i mean i
it seems crazy given with the
announcement that they may but that's
in flux your wolverines may yet take the
field uh
sooner than you'd expect but i'm not
breaking a story that's just kind of
um that's potentially what could happen
but
you know besides that the games we know
that are going to happen and just
there's a few leagues that are up and
running the sec gets up and running in a
couple weeks but the schedule is very
much up in the air
so typical no that's the reason why look
i i know again you you've had your
your head and your voice in the game at
u.s open tennis and then you know you
got to turn around and get ready for an
nfl game
tonight that's why i asked you about
your schedule because
yeah do you know like what your next i i
know that's kind of crazy to ask this if
somebody i wish they could hit the tape
and collapse after
um two weeks plus in the bubble over
there and that's this challenge tonight
but no we're back miami at louisville uh
saturday as an ecc
game uh that is the first game and then
then we're sort of off and running after
that it'll be a mixed bag but
um we're just glad to be calling games
man i bet
i know that i know we spoke over the
summer and
we're like i i don't know nfl and now
here you are
coming off of a successful u.s open uh
tournament getting set to call monday
night football
between the giants and the steelers um
how how did you prepare for this
doing all that what you've done like
walk me through it
uh right down to the first tee i mean
it'll be a you know
it's it's a lot man you know the the
amount of information
at your disposal i thought we got a lot
of it in college it's
beyond in the nfl so you're you're
sifting and sorting and discarding and
figuring out how not to smother a
telecast i mean
my tendency probably is to over prepare
and overplay so i'll try to guard
against that tonight
but it's been a process over the month
you try to
you try to like get ready for it but
then i what i didn't realize rich
there's about half the players on an nfl
board right so it should be easier right
but the fluidity of the roster is right
down to the last minute
didn't you don't have that in college
right you don't sign a dude
who's on the field five days later
starting against the steelers
the the giants roster in particular as
you probably know it's just very fluid
but there's so many new faces and
so i tried to get ready but it's it's
gonna take every minute i've got and
then we're just gonna have
it's sort of a one-off that's the one
game we'll do this year and and um
it's really cool for me to see guys that
i got to know in college
and you following through that draft
night and you're proud of what they did
in a detached way but you feel like you
get to know them and so
it's really cool to reconnect with guys
like
you know tj watt and you know dexter
lawrence and
and jibril peppers and saquon barkley i
mean these are guys that we got
a pretty and now these guys talk as
very mature men and you know veterans of
the league it's
kirk and i both feel the same way in
maria as well it's just it's fun we're
going to enjoy that aspect of it tonight
yeah i was going to ask you like did you
go back to some of your saquon notes
from penn state games or even like
your college game day maybe with miami
of ohio on the schedule with big ben
from 2003 like did you did you go into
your archives
in prep for today i was laughing ben
said he was more nervous for this game
tonight
because how is he missing last year and
not wanting to let the teammates down
and he has been since the max
championship game
uh which he was in college which kirk i
think was broadcasting so we're having a
laugh about that but
no i i i think i would be
idiotic to sit there and start spinning
old tales about dudes what they did in
college i mean
these guys are pros our audience expects
us to refer to them as pro football
players
i mean it's inevitable that we're going
to have an anecdote or two because
right i think it's interesting um but
we're not going to overdo that for sure
did you zoom with joe judge in between
u.s open
tennis matches did you do something like
that chris my day yesterday was
resumed with the giant players in the
morning before i left for the
uh the stadium yeah set up in the booth
before the final for
the joe judge zoom called the final
during the match the steelers zooms were
recorded unfortunately it couldn't be a
part of that
but then went home at night after the
final tried to decompress and
listened to all the zoom calls from
tomlin
ben connor all the pittsburgh players it
was quite a day
and and and of course as you're trying
to prepare for monday night chris you
get the first us open champion in 71
years to come from the first two sets
down like team did so you got that going
forward exactly
when it's like two sets below for all
zvero with six points from winning i
think okay this is going to be a crap
final
it's going to be remembered as a bad
final but at least i'll have a few more
hours to prep
but you can't get caught you know three
hours later this is a pretty damn
memorable final and i just lost three
hours but you know listen
you want to always call great matches
when when the final
of a tournament is a dud it it's just
poor punctuation for the event
there's so much went into staging this
u.s open i mean against all odds it
actually came off really well
they people did not get infected it was
the safety record was really good
i'm glad glad we got a final that if not
aesthetically pleasing throughout at
least was dramatic at the end and two
guys who could barely
walk or stand up kind of emptying the
bucket that's kind of cool to see
chris fowler a couple more minutes left
with chris before he goes into metlife
and calls the
giants and the steelers tonight what a
fun matchup that's going to be and i i
can't wait to sit down and watch it i
hope so i hope the giants can hang with
him frankly i i i have some concerns but
if we get a great game it's
a bonus well i mean again and seeing
what big ben looks like chris
obviously that is a monster story line
for
2020 if the big ben that we have come to
know
as a first ballot surefire hall of famer
shows up
um and starts winging it around and juju
smith schuster
from 2018 show uh starts materializing
on the screen
then we may have a different afc that
we're talking about that's what we're
talking
about there i i know there i know
everybody's given the division of
baltimore but a lot of folks that kirk
and others who have
been diving into pittsburgh if exactly
what you said
happens um they're not only a surefire
playoff team a lot of people think they
can go
go deep in the playoffs um but we'll see
it'd be fun to watch tonight for sure
certainly um
and then i guess last one for your pod
that um that's
dropping soon let's let's talk about
that i i know
quite a bit about it since i'm on the
first one uh that you are producing
uh with uh jennifer your lovely
fantastic better half
uh i give you the floor on this chris
you're you're part of a very
flattering four by one relay willie
geist maria taylor you and then jeremy
shep running the anchor leg
i don't know what we were thinking i
mean we had four great storytellers
it's a ton of content we didn't edit out
too much of it but it is like an hour
it's a double album um so i but it's
it's really an interesting look you guys
were all great it's about
talking to people which is the essence
of a podcast and
and it's not going to be a sports pod
it's different topics that kind of
interests me and i hope others
but but you guys were all great and so
we we just said let's just debut with
the double album
i mean i think people will enjoy the
stories and and i
very appreciate you giving your time to
come on
um possibly slightly delayed there's
more to this than i thought i'm a newbie
at this thing
but by certainly by midweek wherever you
find your podcast
it should be it should be dropped or
released or whatever whatever they do
with the podcast what's the name of it
what are we what are we looking for what
what's the
uh is that who you got virtually we
found out that every
not in the sports context you get that
annoying question i'm sure you get that
annoying question
john madden got that question when i
first met him i was shadowing him as an
eager young college kid and people like
hey john who you got
and i saw how grumpy he got when he got
that question
and you get it all the time but this is
in relation to who we got in terms of
guests
so okay every podcast name is taken
by three other podcasts out there if you
didn't know that you try to come up with
something that hasn't hasn't been used
and since um 77 percent of americans
have a podcast
it's sort of like everything is taken
but
i mean uh just just fowler podcast that
it's easy to find that way
okay all right uh so i i i i
enjoyed the chat it is a great idea
where you talk to people who talk to
people for a living
and you you you have a conversation
about having a conversation
and when things go a little bit uh awry
when they
when they shake and i know you told the
story on dan's show
uh when you appeared last week right
here on peacock but you do have to
enlighten my viewers because you
enlightened me
to this story um uh that
you told about bert reynolds i want to
give you the floor here
chris to finish up strong i'll do the
i'll do the uh
the truncated version because i don't
want to tell along
the time but no it's it basically is a
it ended up with a 70 something year old
reynolds wanting to punch my lights out
on the field where he used to run around
as a seminole player
but it began backstage at radio city
at least for me that that's that was my
first encounter with burt
i knew him a little bit because he's lee
corso's roommate at fsu and so we
you know he's been around a little bit
he's a football fan and a booster of the
program
um the late legend um
but yeah i'm walking backstage to the
espys
i finished presenting i'm full of myself
it was pretty exciting to be on stage at
radio city and
i'm walking through the dark there's the
curtains and the pulleys backstage and i
feel this
sharp punch to my left shoulder
look out it's burt reynolds hey bert
don't you give me don't you give me that
he's got a finger in my face yeah he he
it was we we talked in the pod it's
interesting you tell a very funny
actually a couple funny mistaken
identity stories this was mine
i i i said nothing to offend burt i
swear i said
nothing in my life why would i talk
about burt reynolds divorce
with lonnie anderson but he was
convinced that i had said something and
i kicked him
down and now he was going to punch me
when i wasn't expecting it
and we started this bizarre feud and and
you know the reason why it's in the pod
is because he wouldn't be interviewed by
me it's an interview that didn't happen
because he would not sit on the gameday
set so he put him a little side set
where he and lee could get it
but yeah i it was a weird situation i've
never i mean now i'll never know the
answer to it because i i
i asked corso please ask your friend
why he hates me why he thinks i said
something
that was the worst thing you'd ever
heard and
leave just shook his head and smiled you
know that's bird i have no idea
so the mystery will go on forever
i'll never know why he punched me and
wanted it you know he
he wanted to throw down on the sidelines
of bill campbell stadium
fantastic and he said you don't want to
fight a 70 year old man
he said no bird i do not
[Laughter]
as i said as i said to you that's a no
win
yes of course you either you either
punch a legend and your career is over
you might go to jail and you might not
get out of there alive
because they love her reynolds or a a
septuagenarian kicks your ass
ask pedro martinez about don zimmer
there's no that's not a win there's no
good
situation there so that's a great
playback away and let him blow off steam
and i went to the other side of the
field to watch the game i
i still have no idea why
and if anybody as somebody who's known
you for as long as i've known you chris
you could not care less about the stuff
like uh burt reynolds and lonnie
anderson and their divorce like
that i don't know how that would have
come up on game day rick i just don't
think that in between
breaking down today's games that would
have come up but
chris you know of all the people out
there that
may have said something i don't know who
he thought i was
as i told you maybe maybe it was you
maybe you said people could have been i
don't think that
you i don't think so i i i don't think
so but that might have
that maybe that's what cost me my
appearance in cannonball run three i
didn't know if that uh that might have
been i mean maybe it was billy bush when
he did the entertainment show i don't
know i mean
that's the kind of show talk about that
not a football show but
we now we're talking about it on the
fowler podcast that'll be dropping later
on this week
uh i'm thrilled about that and susie and
i with the kids could not be more
excited to settle in to watch the game
with you calling it tonight
and i know you're talked out i really
appreciate you spending all this time
talking with me on a big day
thank you now you got to be fired up but
i i think it's uh there's some good good
story lines i hope the game's good and
then
then it's back to the uh back to the
saturday night
battles in the college gridiron i look
forward to a full season on that front
too chris thanks for the call best to
jennifer
take care take care rich thank you you
got it chris fowler
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here